[Music]
we brought together seven sorority girls
I'm in a sorority I'm in a sorority I'm
an S sorority I'm in a sorority I'm in a
sorority I'm in a sorority I'm an
authority one is a liar
if the group discovers who the liar is
they'll split a cash prize
if the liar survives they win the entire
prize
Oh also stay tuned because in this
episode there will be an extra special
surprise I'm in Gamma Phi Beta I'm
awesome Gamma Phi Beta I haven't tried
all time I'm in Delta Gamma
I mean cap Alpha Theta I'm an eighty PI
I'm also encounter Alpha Theta I didn't
think that there would be another person
that was in the same sorority and I
thought if there was and it was a trick
why did you guys decide to stay in your
sorority I stayed because I just had a
lot of like emotional and mental health
support within my sorority I stayed on
because I live in and it's a lot off
campus the first round was really fast
so like we didn't really have time to
figure out like who knew like the most
information your guys's bid day themes
ours was like Space Camp
sweet dreams it was like dreamy ours is
Delta dreamin
ours was DG I think she was just one of
the most enthusiastic ones
she was just asking too much guys I
think I just led the conversation and I
think people just thought because I was
leading it that I was trying to avoid
answering the questions but really I'm
just a really loud person all right
so should we should we each say why we
rush yeah so I rushed because my
roommate was rushing and we kind of
wanted to do it together to kind of see
which ones we can get and also my sister
was a DG so I was a legacy so Ivy
mentioned like a legacy and to me that
was like the thing that was like the
easiest to like know if you weren't in
Greek life do you know like your sign I
[Music]
felt like she was trying really hard to
convince us all that she was in a
sorority
I am an assorted yeah so I'm really in a
sorority too
he said I really am innocent already I
know I like fit the like Serio type and
that might be like why not but like I am
I just got slated in to having a
position it's something I'm really
passionate about and I really am mm yeah
I love my sorority and we're doing girls
on the run we have a 5k actually ECI
December 7th so every one of that she
was a little bit quiet and she was
mumbling and when she was talking she
wasn't making eye contact with anyone
else I thought I was gonna be eliminated
the whole time no I felt like there were
some people gunning for me I'm thank you
I'm director of social events when she
said that I was like hey she's for sure
in a sorority
what is your guys's least favorite thing
about being in a sorority someone who is
in a sorority might like see it as like
this positive experience where like
everyone loves each other and there's no
like wrong in it
so I thought it would be harder for the
mole to like make up an answer to that
question I don't like the stereotype
that goes along with it
my friends a lot of them are in
sororities actually besides like the
ones that are in my sorority and
sometimes they like just make comment
and they're like oh like that's a
sorority girl thing or like they're like
oh yeah I'm like well it's it's really
like not like that at all for the most
part people look at a sorority girl as
someone who's extremely skinny white
blond overly preppy when you have people
like me who don't fit any of those it's
kind of annoying because people assume
that
this is just a group for these people
when it shouldn't be what houses were
you guys between like like your on last
night it was for me it was G fine kappa
[Music]
if you've brought up the legacy thing
you probably had a good chance of not
being in a sorority I guess I just
wasn't as stereotypical sorority as they
wanted my name is Ciara and I'm in a
sorority hi Sierra I'm Brianna Brianna
Charlotte Ashley Ashley oh she scared me
a little bit to be honest um so I
graduated from SDSU I was in a Kairos so
yeah really fun I feel like people
describe me as like a sorority girl
anyway so I don't want to overcompensate
and like well we could do our chance
know just how much your guys's dues per
like quarter like semester since I
wasn't in the initial part of the game I
knew they would have suspicions well it
was split up but I think it was like two
thousand a semester mine is like sixteen
hundred per quarter so you have three
quarters god that's so expensive you
could tell a bunch of us were a little
more reserved like we don't really want
to say like how much our chapter asks us
to pay dues and she was like boom like
sixteen hundred and I'm like oh that's
kind of like daring for you to just say
that out loud if you need help which is
great like there's scholarships and
stuff so I like to break that stereotype
it's not that expensive it's like what
you make of it Polly
I just trusted the other two more and so
it was just kind of like I had to put
her down kind of thing it was like your
least favorite part of being a part of
story honestly I feel like just the
stereotype I feel like people definitely
pen girls that were in a sorority as a
certain way when I feel like I found
like people I'm Federer can me my
weddings or like I thought they helped
me grow to be a better person and I feel
like I don't know a sorority gave me
that type of community so what are like
the biggest takeaways you've gotten
since like you're not in a sorority
anymore like what are the biggest things
you've got from being in it I could take
shots like a obviously just the
relationships are home like it's not
just like it's not for four years it's
for life and it's just like it really is
I feel like I just taught me a lot of
things about just I don't know what a
community can do sit still like paying
it forward for me yeah we just wanted to
be a hundred percent so
I brushed so I like almost joined Creek
life but then I decided to drop because
I decided like I didn't want to be part
of it so it was kind of fun like doing
this since I had gone through a show I
had like some experience with it I did
not expect her to be the mole at all she
knew just enough which was like so
shocking at the end of the day I've
never found myself with my me there's no
I feel like it's really hard to turn
down
oh that's a sorority girl because
they're just like any other girl yeah
let's do a green one that's fun all
right
hello thank you for watching this
episode of odd man out feel free to
comment like subscribe anything else you
could do with the YouTube channel feel
free to do it we have an Instagram it'll
be on the screen here here or here or I
don't know where it'll be maybe it won't
be on the screen but we do have it even
if it's on the screen thank you so much
bye how many ways can I say this